is Holmes and Watson really that bad
apparently it is since it's Christmas
Day release critics and audiences alike
have been teaming up to tear the project
apart with even the rare good reviews
still describing considerable portions
of the movie s painful
that's not how comedy is supposed to
work here's why Holmes and Watson bombed
whatever excitement there was for Holmes
and Watson was mostly due to the
presence of its two lead actors john c
reilly and will ferrell the comedic duo
first came together in a big way for the
2006 country-fried comedy Talladega
Nights The Ballad of Ricky Bobby a
send-up of NASCAR and southern style
culture that brought in over a hundred
and sixty-two million dollars at the
global box office a gifted pop culture
with quotes that have withstood the test
of time that collaboration was followed
in 2008 by the even more enduring ly
beloved Step Brothers which earned over
a hundred and twenty eight million
dollars globally though Reilly and
Ferrell haven't gotten any less funny
over the years their appeal as a comedic
duo managed to fail them with Holmes and
Watson a week after its release the
movie had only earned around twenty four
million dollars against an estimated
budget of at least 42 million dollars
not exactly the sign of a successful
reunion notoriously low review scores
weren't the only bad press Holmes and
Watson received during its roll out the
day after its theatrical release
deadline reported that the people
responsible for Holmes and Watson had
actually tried to prevent the movie from
having a theatrical release at all
instead executives tried to pass it off
to Netflix in an effort to contain the
damage and offer which Netflix obviously
refused reporter Anthony D'Allesandro
wrote test scores for Holmes and Watson
were so bad that Sony tried unloading
the movie the Netflix but the streamer
wouldn't buy it it's important to keep
in mind that Netflix is the streaming
platform responsible for the ridiculous
six a movie that has been consistent in
its zero percentage rating on Rotten
Tomatoes it has been noted that the
marketing campaign for Holmes and Watson
was curiously muted in fact if not for
the wickedly poor reception the movie
received it's possible you never would
have heard of it when a studio was
confident it has a hit on its hands like
with Sony's own spy
man into the spider-verse it tends to
get the word out early and promote the
film as often and widely as possible in
the case of Holmes and Watson Sony
seemingly threw it into the crowded
holiday mixed crossed some fingers and
hoped no one would get too mad Holmes
and Watson only managed to rake in
enough money to earn a number 7 spot at
the domestic box office during its
opening weekend this place the brand-new
release behind second weekend
performances of Aquaman Mary Poppins
returns and bumblebee as well as the
third weekend runs of spider-verse and
the mule Holmes and Watson's only saving
grace would be positive word-of-mouth
but even that seems scarce mr. Holmes
the Empire is depending on you though
fortunes have certainly turned for
movies with less than impressive debuts
such as the remarkable run of 2017 s
that greatest showman Holmes and Watson
seemed to sorely lack any crowd-pleasing
qualities that could redeem itself in
short Holmes and Watson failed at the
box office because it was a failure of a
film simply put the so-called comedy
couldn't ignite the same passionate
response as previous collaborations
between it's capable leads resulting in
an inability to attract audiences in the
middle of a crowded holiday season the
broad critical consensus is that Holmes
and Watson is just not worth seeing even
for curiosity's sake at its best Holmes
and Watson is on the same level of
quality as some of those cut for time
Saturday Night Live sketches the kind
that didn't make it into the actual live
broadcast for good reason the detective
work here is simply Elementary you'd be
better off spending your money on nachos
they got a whole mess of nachos sounds
good right now check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]